Thank you very much,
members of the Academy.
First, I have to
thank my father.
And my father.
This is for my father.
Thank you to my dad for
everything he taught me.
To you, Dad.
You taught me what
it means to be a man.
You know, my dad didn't get
to see me do any of this,
but I think he's looking
down on me right now.
I want to thank my
father up there,
the man who, when I said I
wanted to be an actor, he said,
wonderful.
Just have a backup
profession like welding.
All those days of listening
to Sly and the Family Stone
and Marvin Gaye,
they really paid off.
So thank you, Dad.
Dad.
[LAUGHS] [SNIFFS]
Well, you know.
And especially to my
father, I love you
more than anything in the world.
When you give me this award, you
honor my father, Paul Sorvino,
who has taught me everything
I know about acting.
I want to thank my
daughter, for telling me
just before I got up here,
if you don't win, Dad,
you're still good.
[LAUGHTER]